suis à saint-aigulin en
charente-maritime je vais rencontrer
jean françois ahuili à 13 ans cet homme
père son fils damien le sergent damian
d'huile étaient engagés dans l'armée
française en afghanistan il est tombé
dans une embuscade des talibans dans la
vallée d'uzbin bonjour monsieur bul
merci à beaucoup de répondre à nos
questions alors vous vous présentez
comme un homme en colère pourquoi tout
simplement parce que
ce que je vois à la télévision
aujourd'hui ça me supportent je vois les
talibans et qui rentre à kaboul en toute
tranquillité après ça vous met à
spécifiquement colère parce que nos
soldats sont morts pour rien mon fils
est mort pour rien alors le mot rien on
meurt on me le reproche pour me disant
c'est pas possible mais s'ils sont morts
pour rien la preuve c'est un échec total
on est à saint-aigulin en charente
maritime ce lieu je crois qu'il est
spécial pour vous pourquoi mais ici on
est près du monument aux morts en 2009
le hervé morin qui était à ce moment là
le ministre des armées avec dominique
bussereau qui était à ce moment là
ministre des transports sont venus
déposer cette cette plaque en l'honneur
de mon fils mort le 18 août 2008 us been
avec neuf de ses camarades donc c'est un
lieu pour moi qui mets qui représente
tout court en fait on est à 13 ans après
le décès de votre fils qu'est ce que
vous sentez aujourd'hui en venant ici à
chaque fois j'ai de l'émotion alors si
vous voulez j'ai pu j'ai toujours je
suis toujours triste parce que toute
façon le bon on a toujours ça dans la
tête à chaque fois puis aujourd'hui avec
tout ce qui se passe ce qu'on voit à la
télé à chaque fois où ça revient mon
conjoint hélicoptère passe et bombay
j'ai la gorge serrée quoi ça me je suis
je suis mais l'avait ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui je suis je suis désespéré je
suis écoeuré je suis là je suis matraque
et donc on est à le 18 août 2008 donc
c'est donc la date où votre fils est
décédé comment est ce que vous apprenez
la nouvelle mais on apprend la nouvelle
le matin
un coup de téléphone le téléphone se met
à sonner c'est mon épouse qui répond et
c'est les pousses de son meilleur copain
qui était en afghanistan qui était
soldat également qui lui apprenait que
paie notre fils était décédé avec neuf
de ses camarades
voilà c'est tout on n'a pas eu la visite
de gendarmes n'ayant mer rien du tout
même le régime en rien du tout mais
j'estime que quand même
les gendarmes c'est leur rôle et surtout
le maire de la commune c'est son rôle
mais même pas un coup de téléphone rien
donc là
quand même petit malaise il avec l âge
de 6 il avait 31 ans il est décédé le
jour de ses 31 ans puisqu'il est né le
18 août 2000
1977 et donc 31 ans après le même jour
il décédé je suis aux chambres regardez
là là il est
là il est en afghanistan voilà il est
sûre le sur le vab voilà
c'est c'est notre fils vous avez entamé
un combat judiciaire
pourquoi après après le décès de notre
fils un an après on a
on a trouvé on a pensé en réfléchissant
tout en discutant avec les soldats qui
étaient qui était revenu qui était
intervenu qui avait pas été blessés
d'autres blessés on sait on s'est
rencontrés et ils nous ont un petit peu
raconté ce qui s'était passé parce que
des versions on en a eu des versions de
la mort de notre fils puis de tous ses
copains mais la vraie version c'est la
version de ceux qui étaient sur le
terrain il ya eu plein de de dysfonction
il ya eu plein de choses qui a
manquements un manquement donc
nous on pouvait pas on n'a pas su porter
ça c'est un combat je dis ça qui est
aujourd'hui terminée est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de ce que vous avez de ce
que vous en avez obtenu le ce combat n'a
pas été vain donc on n'a pas eu bien sûr
le résultat parce que escompté puisque
nous on aurait voulu que les
protagonistes de la faire c'est à dire
ces officiers qui n'ont pas été à la
hauteur de la mission à moi je regrette
je le dis franchement ils ont eu tout ce
sont tous montés en grade ils ont été
mutés tranquillou ppm alors dans leurs
bottes et jean-françois avis l'ouest ce
qu'on veut c'est ce que l'on est là on
aussi une guerre de saint-aigulin là où
notre fils est d'enterrer dans cette
petite chapelle suite aux évènements du
18 août 2008 en afghanistan et à écrire
tombés pour la liberté dans le monde
pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi cette
formule parce que nos considère avec sa
maman que notre fils et b il n'est pas
mort pour la france et il est mort sur
les terres d'afghanistan donc nous
considérons nous nous seuls et ce
langage que nous sommes inquiets qu'il
est mort pour la paix dans le monde
comment est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous gérer
toutes ces émotions tous ces sentiments
aubin on les gère tout seul vous savez
là j'en parle avec mon épouse lors je
m'énerve tout seul devant la télé et
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire alors on
en parle aussi avec notre association
delpal au delà père à l'olivier une
association en fait pour les les parents
qui ont perdu un enfant lors d'un
conflit militaire sinon c'est très
compliqué de parler de ces événements
avec une personne lambda est ce que ne
comprend pas vous savez 13 ans après
pour beaucoup
c'est très très loin pour nous c était
hier voilà